you filmed this in rural Massachusetts I
did and I grew up not in rural
Massachusetts I grew up near Boston but
where I grew up in Brookline which is
hide outside is your address oh I tell
you but it's still our address no it's
my my parents still live in the house
that I grew up in and when I go home I
go into a room and there's like you know
pictures of the bedroom yeah it's my
childhood bedroom like a picture on the
wall of like you know the guy in the
Partridge Family
it's no it's just
it's yeah so they still live there so I
can't give that information out guys
don't you want to know his job
15:15 Mockingbird Lane Herman Munster
let's look it up this is really these
are great references yeah yeah
and part of this show is to educate you
about a long time ago about monster
Sitka it tracks that you're from there
by the way why not try seven months in
rural Massachusetts you just seem the
type to be from wait a minute I don't
know whether I'm being complimented or
whether it's I love what you're doing
right now I'm intrigued you just spent
all this time Massachusetts like yep you
seem like the type so what do you want
to say about that well I
okay I love Massachusetts I think it's
great I thought it was very very
beautiful I was in the middle of nowhere
though yeah we just kind of were dropped
there and told to find housing so I
picked a farm it was dark
the house was big a little scary it
sounds like the plot of the movie but
it's not this is not really
they just said hey Lizzie you're gonna
be shooting a film here and you had you
just went and found a farm and yet
they're yeah yeah you rented a farm you
didn't you didn't just knock on
someone's door
[Music]
it's almost that to be on I moved around
a lot I couldn't find my place and they
really didn't help us out very much they
really just gave us like a pile of money
and said go find a place to live so I
picked a farm because I've never lived
on a farm and that seemed like a really
good idea right and this is what you
were on the farm I'm not cut out for the
farm that is very clear it was an
organic farm so they didn't spray for
any bugs
oh and New England there's some bugs I
don't know if you've heard there's some
bugs including ticks oh yeah this isn't
the Jerry Springer Show and after the
break those ticks will be coming out
they're gonna take a pregnancy test so
wait a minute so yeah text her a real
problem they're a huge problem and it's
getting worse and I have never lived in
a place with a tick problem an issue
with ticks and I did not cope at all I
would sit in my farmhouse in the kitchen
it was a heat wave I wore full sleeves
pants tucked into pretreated insect
guard socks I covered myself in DEET and
then I just sat at one chair in one
chair in the kitchen I had a huge I just
sat in this chair googling ticks did you
find ticks on you well no but that's not
it
well it sounds like there was no way a
tick was ever gonna get no they weren't
well my dog I had my dog with me and she
I mean I pumped her full of like every
possible tick thing she had the collar
all the meds so if a tick bit my dog it
would immediately like person to flames
her but she what she was like the
chauffeur like they would get on her and
then she would take them into the house
and then they would start looking for me
she she was she was the lyft driver for
ticks yeah and they do they do that they
hunt you like okay takes I think you
lost your mind a little bit I think you
were on this farm alone yeah exactly I
think you were alone for long periods of
time and you're like they come after you
they do you hunt you one would think
that that cuz it sounds like that but if
you Google am I overreacting about ticks
everything is like no they're coming for
you you don't know when it bit you and
you die and it didn't affect you in 15
minutes and then your brain swells and
you die yeah but that's the internet
about everything if you type in should I
be fear clouds fear cloud they murder
tonight you're probably correct but yeah
I could see I mean that's the thing is
you you didn't grow up in Massachusetts
and it didn't used to be a problem but
Massachusetts Connecticut all that area
you pictures everywhere
apps on the grass right when you were a
boy I did everything on the grass
every day except have sex I that didn't
happen till you know my late 40s